god this is not fair man videos are
taking years off my life I'm John I'm a
private investigator today I've been
asked by BuzzFeed
for some reason to figure out which one
of these subjects is the boss how about
you would you join me yeah baby
Aiden yeah let's meet you that's my
first question where you from from
Connecticut originally where you live
now I live in LA so we're like what do
you do I work at buzzer what you do I
work in media management I'm not I'm the
lead their media management that sounds
kind of vague so I actually work with
family here we each have one person
under us we do a lot of archiving and
then like redistribution of videos so
does stuff come off of for example like
eventually get pulled off the social
channels but you guys have to back it up
on drives yeah like like glorified
librarians okay right on who's your boss
me you're the boss well I mean I'm with
in post-production but yeah I'm a lead
you have employees that report to you or
that are like under you yeah there's
three you're a lead you said yeah okay
what's your football team 49ers I'm not
like jets-giants don't subscribe to
those teams
okay are you an East Coast guy you seem
offended no I like talking sports okay I
I find it interesting more than anything
but no Tom Brady's brother I'm not
personally a affronted no well you said
you do work with standard area
okay so what's his role he does more
like the archiving side of things I do
like the redistribution side of things
how did you get the job through a friend
of mine actually were there any sort of
like cloak-and-dagger behind closed
doors turning people against him kind of
plotting his downfall anything
Shakespearean going on the big time yeah
okay so that would indicate you're more
of like a team effort
not necessarily the boss so how long you
been working at BuzzFeed about a year
and a half all right well I think I'm
good for now Aiden why don't you join me
please oh wow what's your name yes to me
what do you do here destiny video
producer and manager what does that
really mean I kind of just help
facilitate making sure all the needs are
met for production look over the videos
leave notes what does that mean making
than needs or Matt I guess they have any
questions about like production or like
the shoots that we have or like just
working with like the editors or just
making sure everyone that's cool yeah
but what is that I don't know okay so
like use this as an example this is one
of the producers ideas to shoot this
video yeah it's a place to shoot it he
has to book this room right and schedule
it right does that run through you at
all no oh yeah like a production team
with like coordinators who kind of
handle that do they have anything to do
with you I mean I talk to them sometimes
but not really okay what is something
that your subordinates would need that
they would come to you asking for a lot
of meetings I don't think they're like
oh I need that destiny he needs to
approve this or see this it's more of
like sounds easy to us there most bosses
don't really do any work so true that
how are you I'm good are you I'm a
little down I got my last one of these
videos wrong so I'm kind of really hit
my ego harder than I thought
all right you got me I was close but
yeah but I had a good run there for a
while also I really have no idea what
the point of this video is I don't even
know why I'm here really sort of an
existential thing I'm going through I
just don't even know what questions to
ask you so I'm just kind of making small
talk
no that's fine have you seen any movies
lately really lately I've seen three
this weekend I'm like dying to talk
about movies but how long have you
worked here seven months so who's your
boss I'm the boss it's weird even bosses
here have bosses like it just the right
stop like it you know am I supposed to
figure out who these three of these
people work for one of the other fourth
one is that it's really are not actually
leaders or managers so they're all
telling me they're managers there's
really no way of you knowing I hope you
know that okay I don't really need that
right now all right well that makes
sense because you can't really seem to
explain to me what a manager does yeah
so maybe you don't know anything about
it what's your biggest strengths in
communication what do you think is a
weakness
that you may need to work on
professional time management you keep
getting pulled away to do these videos
so maybe you could speak to your boss
about that
Thanks destiny I think I'm okay for now
you can you can head on back to the wall
if you want will you join me
sure hello what's up what are you doing
here
I actually lead a team for the archiving
department of our I guess this company
how BIG's your team it's like four
people take me through like a day or
like a week with the archive department
because I guys honest truth it's all
digital so yeah how hands-on is an
archiving process even you can kind of
get away with doing a lot of nothing but
there's a ton of videos being made here
and then we distribute it to our team
and then they have to like upload it to
a cloud we otherwise have like these
hard drives but they archaic and it's
that's only we're phasing out that's
technical stuff as a matter of principle
I don't trust clouds I mean I trust
drives damn I got to be able to run into
my burning house and like grab something
and run out with it but if it's on the
cloud you don't even have to go into the
burning house to begin with yeah but
eventually the clouds gonna be the brain
house you have to talk to my boss
subordinates about that one but
subordinates I mean you know it's it's a
big company everyone's got a boss here
calling you work here going on okay year
how'd you get the job my former roommate
just kind of like plug me in I need up
the interview how about that showed up
one day technically yeah a nepotism -
hell of a thing did you go to college
went to the University of New Orleans it
was otherwise known as the University of
no opportunity yeah Here I am
okay so for people under you and what do
they do they have to like make sure
everything's there and then they have to
like put it up in the cloud so
everyone's like editing projects but no
one really knows what they're doing so
you know they'll give us these projects
but though they won't realize that like
half the stuff in the actual video is
like on their desktop so you think all
of the editors at BuzzFeed are kind of
hacks and they're not good at what they
do now I mean some of them are some of
them are I can pinpoint some probably
not the best idea I can't - it's two
pens here please put that down
Thank You Stanley thanks for now I think
I'm done yeah perhaps we'll chat later
will you join me uh what's your name
Becky what do you do I'm an attorney
here at BuzzFeed so what do you do on a
daily basis I do a lot of rights and
clearances reviews I confirm with our
media management team to make sure that
all necessary releases for people who
are not BuzzFeed employees are signed
and archived and properly put with the
videos I negotiate contracts both talent
for internal and external people duction
releases location agreement see this is
why I don't get invited to parties
I swear I'm fun what's your title staff
attorney do you have people that report
to you one directly and then I help out
some folks in New York do you want to
know if I've seen any movies I never get
the fun questions yeah I guess you're
right I'm more than a set of law books
you know all right well I think I'm done
for now Becky thanks oh well this is
just impossible to figure out without
just taking a wild guess it's almost
like these videos have nothing to do
with being a private investigator at all
Becky
talks to talk she's obviously a lawyer
but eventually I just kind of snapped
out of it and realized my brain had shut
off because she just kept talking about
it
destiny I'm pretty sure I know for a
fact is a figure of some kind of
authority here at BuzzFeed I kept asking
her to describe what she does and it
really doesn't sound like she has a job
at all Eden I've never seen before so
maybe he's so important he usually can't
be bothered to come down here and shoot
these things also referred to his job
position as glorified librarians also he
talked to me in the green room Stan Lee
was talking a lot about what it means to
be a boss he said there's four people
who work under him
Eden said there's only one seems like
maybe Eden told a lie and Stanley had to
back it up which begs the question why
would Hayden lie for Stan Lee Becky's
not in with me
I think it's a good question this guy's
a troll
Stanley's getting defensive well let me
see this I think Becky should be the
boss
maybe I don't talk about movies with her
as much because I'm intimidated by her
powerful women scare me
these videos are taking years off my
life is gonna destroy me if I get this
wrong I could be anybody they're all in
my head this is just unpleasant destiny
will you come sit here
where'd you work before this Amazon
doing what video pretty funny where was
that was this up in Washington yeah okay
calling you live in LA about seven
months how BIG's your staff people how
many videos do they produce a week 50
videos every month two months every two
months it's really confusing I would
really love to spend all day breaking it
down but I'm okay so what are your
deliverables define deliverables what
the hell do you do we've been through
this John I do manage a small team of
producers I thought I'm not like behind
them like do this do that it's more so
just like overseeing them I watch them
okay thanks
Eden will you come back please yeah
thanks yes
where did you work before BuzzFeed I
worked in Showtime in New York for a
while and small Persian company called
born ready films as well
what'd you do at Showtime for example I
was in their creative services
department so I was less pa what's your
favorite movie
Google hunting please your favorite
actor may be Christian Bale okay yeah
thank you yeah Becky will you join me
here so do you run the legal department
well no so we have a GC and then
underneath the GC we have general
counsel under that we have associate
general well don't okay oh we have
associate general counsel zai reporting
to the associate general counsel for IP
okay do you like country music yeah
who's your favorite country musician
either Dolly Parton or Patsy Cline
what's your favorite TV show of all time
Six Feet Under
ah all right thanks yeah I appreciate
that man possible you know it's better
to just be completely duped what's worse
is when I feel closer I almost get it
but I'm off a little bit all right
so Becky tells me she's not the boss and
look we got it we got to talk
Street I've seen destiny and Becky a lot
in these circumstances but what does
that mean do you think of someone you
think of someone you know was important
or like in charge they wouldn't be
bothered with this sort of thing I've
never seen a de nin my life not that
that matters really I mean there's lots
of people I haven't seen yet Stanley and
I it's the first time we've sparred
battle of whit's not for me Aidan talks
the talk it did catch him in some
inconsistencies it's silly random it
could be Becky Becky would love to get
one over on me
Aidan likes Christian Bale I respect
that I think it's destiny you know I'm
gonna be having nightmares about you
where he says I should be the boss
though and add that to my LinkedIn now
I'm in a good mood these guys know I was
in a very bad mood before this video
began god this is not fair man Becky
talked a lot as I mentioned iced I
couldn't I could I wanted to process it
I do find it very interesting but I took
a lot of notes on Aidan and I obviously
you must work in this world nothing
anybody was like completely lying to me
except Stan Lee aren't you an editor no
okay well I guess I was wrong I was like
if Becky was like at the top of the food
chain of legal she's got to have more
important things to do than these videos
my definition any if any of these people
is in charge or the manager or whatever
the shtick is the same logic applies I
thought about destiny and I've observed
sometimes how people kind of interact
with her out and about in the hallways
and stuff there's a certain there's this
kind of a deference there I don't know
if she was saw the truth but the way she
described being a manager you just watch
other people do their jobs I guess was
kind of convincing I think Aidan came in
here he wanted a kill and he almost got
me and listening to Becky talk about how
big BuzzFeed is and how vast their whole
legal spiderweb is I just felt like if
you were in charge of that you would you
probably don't even like the inner
you know you probably like live and
breathe like law and you know whatever
tort reform or whatever the hell boy
lawyers do I don't know so ultimately I
got Becky off the list and destiny was
the last one there I was not convinced
of destiny but she had the least things
going against her so that's that there's
stress here there's pressure but you
know that's that's what heroes have to
go through I guess
[Music]
[Music]